Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Tag. Ich bin Issa Alton.
Ich bin der Adienshabender Arzt in dieser Praxis.
Und ich möchte gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Ist das in Ordnung so für Sie?
Ja, Herr Doktor, alles klar.
Aber haben Sie Nachsicht mit mir?
Ich kann nicht so gut reden, weil ich ganz schwer Luft bekommen muss.
Okay, das kann ich gut verstehen.
So darf ich Ihre Name fragen.
Mein Name ist Reina Kalmunt.
Okay. Herr Kalmunt?
Ja, Nachname ist Kalmunt.
Reina, Nachname ist Kalmunt.
Könntest du Sie bitte Ihre Name buchen?
Ja, Kalmunt hat man mit K, A, L, M, U, N, D.
Kalmunt.
Ja, A, I, N, E, Reina.
Okay. Herr Kalmunt, haben Sie schwer Luft?
Bitte, Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, ich habe ganz stark Atemnot.
Ich kann kaum sprechen mit Ihnen.
Okay. Seit wann?
Ja.
Herr Doktor, es ist seit gestern Nachmittag zu einem schlechter geworden.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe sowieso Probleme mit der Atmung,
aber seit gestern kann ich kaum zur Toilette gehen.
So stark ist die Atemnot.
Okay.
Haben Sie dabei Brustschmerz oder nicht?
Ein bisschen eng ist mir auch auf der Brust, ja.
Und nicht so wie beim Herzenfakt vor einem Jahr, da war es anders.
Ich hatte schon mal Herzensfakt.
Haben Sie früher Bechwerden erlebt oder ist das um Herzen?
Nein, das kommt schon so ein bis zweimal im Jahr vor,
wo ich dann schlechter Luft bekomme.
Aber bei mir ist auch festgestellt die COPD-Krankheit.
Dann kommt es immer wieder mal vor, dass die Luft schlechter ist,
aber dass sie jetzt so lange anhält, die Verstechterung ist jetzt neu.
Meistens kann ich mit mir spreesen und etwas helfen,
aber seit gestern wird es nicht besser.
Okay. Wann wurde bei Ihnen COPD festgestellt?
Das sind jetzt schon, glaube ich, 10 Jahre, mindestens.
10 Jahre.
Okay.
Können wir das Aufnahmigespräch durchführen?
Ich habe jetzt Sauerstoff bekommen von der Schwester,
damit geht es einigermaßen, ja.
Ja, ja. Okay.
Sie geben sofort Sauerstoff
und jetzt können wir das Aufnahmigespräch führen.
Ja, mit der Autopizie.
Okay.
Und Herr Kalmund, bevor Sie Ihre Beschwerden ersellen,
möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ich meine, basic auf Ihr Altagrass und Gewicht.
Wie alt sind Sie bitte?
Ich bin jetzt 67 Jahre alt.
67 Jahre alt?
Ja.
Okay.
Wann wurden Sie geboren?
5. März 1957.
1957.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Also ungefähr 1,70 m und ich wiege knapp über 100, so 105 kg, glaube ich.
Über 100.
Okay.
Und Herr Kalmund, Sie haben gesagt, seit gestern Nachmittag haben Sie Atemnot.
Haben Sie eine Spray oder Medikament verwendet?
Ja, das ist das Notfall Medikament Salbutamol.
Das habe ich genommen.
Das sollte ich immer nehmen, wenn es schlechter wird, weil ich habe immer Luftnot.
Und wenn es schlechter werden sollte, sollte ich das nehmen.
Aber das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal genommen, aber es wird nicht besser.
Und dann habe ich noch mein anderes Spray.
Das benutze ich einmal pro Tag.
Das ist aber eine Dauertherapie, die ich schon immer habe.
Also letzten 2, 3 Jahre habe ich dieses Ultipro.
Wie heißt das andere Medikament?
Ultipro heißt das Medikament.
Ultipro?
Ultipro.
Okay.
Das Salbutamol habe ich dann als Bedarf, wenn ich Luftnot habe.
Haben Sie auch Feber oder?
Ich habe es nicht gemessen, Herr Doktor.
Ich weiß nichts.
Ich fühle mich jetzt nicht warm an, aber ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie auch Husten?
Ja, es ist auch mehr geworden der Husten.
Seit wann leiden Sie und Herr Husten?
Das ist die ganze Zeit der Doktor.
Ich habe immer mit Husten zu tun.
Also Atemnot Husten habe ich seit den letzten 5 Jahren fast durchgehend.
Weil es jetzt noch mal etwas mehr geworden ist, der Husten.
Haben Sie auch dabei Auswurf oder Sputten?
Ja, Auswurf habe ich jetzt auch seit ein paar Tagen.
Ja, etwas verfärbt.
Wie sieht das aus, Sputum, Gelbe oder?
Gelbgrün nicht.
Gelbgrün.
Okay.
Und so, Herr Kamund,
gibt es bestimmte Faktoren für die Atemnot,
dass Sie bemerkt haben Sie, leiden Sie,
nur Belastung oder in der Ruhe auch Atemnot?
Also beides.
Ich habe auch eine Ruhe jetzt, Atemnot.
Vorher konnte ich aber noch ein bisschen mich bewegen.
Aber wie gesagt, seit gestern kann ich nicht mehr zur Toilette gehen,
so stark ist die Atemnot.
Sind Ihre Beine angeschwollt?
Ein bisschen, Doktor, ja.
Ein Knöschel.
Beide Beine oder?
Beide, ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden oder Probleme?
Das ist Hauptproblem, Doktor.
Das ist mein Hauptproblem, die Luftnot.
Luftnot?
Okay.
Haben Sie Hausarzt oder Ihre Pulmonärarzt regelmäßig aufgesucht?
Also ich bin regelmäßig beim Hausarzt.
Okay.
Einmal eine Monate.
So, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Kann ich jetzt so nichts sagen, Doktor.
Nichts, keine größeren Probleme.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also normal ist er in Ordnung, aber seit gestern hatte ich also ein bisschen wenig Appetit jetzt auch.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafstörung?
Ja, seitdem ich Luftnot habe, kann ich auch nicht gut schlafen, ja.
Einst du schlafen oder du schlafen?
Beides.
Ich habe auch nicht geschlafen.
Das ist bestimmt aufgerüstet für die Schlafstörung wegen der Atemnot oder?
wegen der Atemnot, ja.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht auf Toilette gehen?
Normalerweise gehe ich so ein bis zweimal immer, ja.
Zweimal?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie viele Kisten benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Ein Kisten habe ich.
Ein Kisten.
Müssen Sie wegen der Atemnot auch wachen?
Also ich habe jetzt nicht geschlafen oder was meinen Sie?
Wie darf ich es verstehen?
Ja.
Herr Kalmont, Sie haben gesagt,
Sarbutamol und Fibrospray,
und noch andere Medikamente?
Ja, wir haben noch viele Medikamente, die ich nehme wegen Herz und so.
Ja, und leiden Sie an bestimmter chronischer Erdverkrocken.
Ja, Herr Doktor, bei mir.
Seit zwei Jahren auch Diabetes festgestellt worden?
Zwei Jahre.
Genau, also Bluthochdruck habe ich ungefähr auch seit zehn Jahren,
wo ich Medikamente einnehme.
Dann ist auch noch die Schaufensterkrankheit festgestellt worden.
Und wie gesagt, letztes Jahr habe ich ein Herzentwack gehabt,
da war ich im Krankenhaus und haben die auch ein Stent gesetzt bei mir.
Das zwei Stents.
Und das waren jetzt so die wichtigsten Krankheiten, glaube ich.
Ja, wann wurde die Chance festgestellt?
Also auch so vor fünf, sechs Jahren bestimmt.
Fünf?
Ja, um für fünf Jahre.
Und wann haben Sie Herzentwack geregelt?
Letztes Jahr.
Und zwei Implanten wurden implantiert.
Und Medikamente, was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck?
Dann nehme ich Ramipri.
Wie stark?
Wie viel Milligramm?
Fünf Milligramm, eine morgens.
Dann habe ich noch Biso Prololl.
Zwei Milligramm, eine morgens, eine abends.
Fünf Milligramm, oder?
2,5 Milligramm.
Morgen?
Morgen und abends.
Abends.
Dann habe ich noch ASS 100.
Dann nehme ich noch Klavix ein.
75.
Dann habe ich noch Attervastatin.
20 Milligramm abends.
Wie viel Milligramm?
20 Milligramm.
Abends.
Dann habe ich noch Metformin.
1000 Milligramm morgens und abends.
Und meine Liste, gucke ich gerade noch mal.
Und Giadaians, 10 Milligramm.
Eine morgens.
Und das Press hatte ich schon gesagt.
Ultibo-Hinlation, einmal pro Tag.
Und Salvatamol bei Bedarf.
Entschuldigung, Metformin?
1000 Milligramm.
Okay.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Aus Erskate der Untersuchung?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal einen Blinddarm gehabt.
Aber das ist schon sehr lange her.
Entschuldigung, als Kind?
Als Kind.
Blinddarm-Operation, ja.
Sonst nichts, sonst bin ich nicht operiert worden.
Okay.
Und sind bei Ihnen
bestimmte Medikamente oder Kontrastmittel aller Gebeckern?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Nein.
Haben Sie gegen Lebensmittel Unferträgigkeit?
Auch nicht.
Und rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider, immer noch, ja.
Ich habe aber noch reduziert.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ich habe mit ungefähr 18 Jahren angefangen,
vielleicht 40 Jahre.
50 Jahre fast.
Wie viel Zigaret rauchen Sie pro Tag?
Jetzt habe ich noch 10, also ein halbes Päckchen.
Vorher waren wir ein Päckchen, habe ich geraucht.
Aber jetzt habe ich so eine.
Wann haben Sie reduziert?
Nach dem Herzenfakt letztes Jahr.
Letztes Jahr.
Davor?
War ein Päckchen so pro Tag.
Ein Päckchen.
Trücken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nein, Alkohol trinke ich nicht.
Ich war Kraftfahrer, da muss ich immer nüchtern bleiben.
Okay.
Herr Kalm, und bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie schon mit Drogenkontaktjärts, oder?
Drogen, nein.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Kalm, und wie ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Ich bin verwittelt seit 3 Jahren.
3 Jahren?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Keine Kinder?
Was sind Sie?
Ich bin Kraftfahrer.
Kraft?
Kraftfahrer.
Okay.
Jetzt arbeiten Sie noch?
Ich bin in Rente.
Ich bin mit einem 63-Vorstand eingetreten.
Unverwärts 3-4 Jahre bin ich jetzt Rente.
Okay.
Herr Kalm, und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, Sie sind beide verstorben.
Beide verschworen.
Darf ich fragen, woran sind Sie gestorben?
Der Vater hatte einen Herzstuhl, also Herzdott, plötzlich.
Und die Mutter ist dann ein Brustkreis verstorben.
Brustkrebs.
Wie alt waren Sie als Stab?
Das war ein Vater, der über 30 Jahre war.
Da war ich 30 Jahre alt.
30?
Da war ich ungefähr 30 Jahre alt.
Und Mutter?
Als mein Vater starb, war ich 30 Jahre alt.
Die ist dann auch kurz später,
um 5-6 Jahre später gestorben.
6 Jahre.
Okay.
Herr Kalm, und ich bin mit meinem Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas Hünsefekun haben Sie eine Frage?
Ich denke, ich muss ja im Krankenhaus bleiben, glaube ich,
nehme ich mal an, oder?
Was denken Sie?
Muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Herr Kalm, zurzeit habe ich eine Verdacht.
Und zurzeit kann ich nicht eine genaue Diagnose sagen.
Aber Sie sollen im Krankenhaus bleiben
und Sie geben Sauerstoff.
Dann werde ich Sie Körperli unterzuholen und dürfen.
Und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen
und Sauerstoff messen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Röntgen
veranlasst,
Torax-Buströntgen veranlasst.
Dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose
sprechen und ob Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Wenn ich im Krankenhaus bleiben,
ich habe morgen einen wichtigen Notatermin.
Wenn ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss,
dann denken Sie, es ist möglich,
dass ich mit dem Sauerstoff, den Sie mir jetzt geben,
mal zum Notat fahren kann und wieder zurückkommen kann.
Dann?
Herr Kalm, ich habe eine Verdacht.
Ich habe einen wichtigen Notatermin.
Wenn ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss,
dann denken Sie, es ist möglich,
dass ich mit dem Sauerstoff, den Sie mir jetzt geben,
mal zum Notat fahren kann
und ich werde dann mit dem Sauerstoff
nach Ihrer Diagnose und den Sieg entscheiden.
Wenn es gut wäre,
dann kann man das machen,
dann denken Sie, dass ich zum Notat fahren kann.
Aber Hauptsache,
Sie werden noch gesund sein.
Okay.
Danke schön, Herr Dr.
Gerne.
Haben Sie einen Kollegen,
oder einen Kollegen,
noch eine Frage?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Also, waren Sie in der letzten Jahr
im Behandlung in einem Krankenhaus für diese Beschwerden?
Ja, ich war im Winter
wegen ähnlicher Beschwerden schon mal im Krankenhaus.
Nur einmal, ja?
Letztes Jahr, also,
letztes Jahr habe ich dann Herzinfarkt.
Das Jahr davor war ich auch schon
zweimal im Krankenhaus gewesen
wegen Luftnoten.
Okay.
Die zweite Frage ist,
haben Sie eine Impfung gegen bestimmte Erregern
vor dem Winter bekommen?
Ja, habe ich. Also, Grippe
und letztes Jahr auch die Pnomokokentimpfung.
Okay. Danke, das war die Frage.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Beheiden Sie bitte.
Haben Sie sich in der Distanz seit Arkite
vor dem Beginn der Beschwerden?
Erkältung?
Ja.
Sie meinen so Schnupfen und so was?
Ja, richtig.
Haben Sie einen Corona-Test gemacht?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Alle Fragen, die unseres Erregern haben...
Es war keine.
Okay.
Was waren die wichtigsten Fragen?
Ja, alle Fragen...
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Schwellung auf ihren Beinen?
Hat er gefragt, aber die Knöcheln sind leicht geschwollen,
beide gleich.
Beides als Knöcheln, über dem.
Herr Kollege, der Patient hat gesagt,
ein Engigevölter in der Brust.
Müssen wir auf uns beschreiben
oder...
Kann man nachfragen.
Er hat gesagt,
der hatte schon mal Herzinfarkt, aber das war anders.
Aber kann man fragen, ob das ausstrahlt.
Typische Ausstrahlung, wie ist der Schulterarm?
Ob es abhängig ist von Belastung?
Die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel.
Danke schön.
Entschuldigung, haben Sie Fieber
oder Schulterfrust?
Fieber hat er gefragt, er hat nicht gemessen
und er fühlt sich nicht warm an.
Schulterfrust hat er nicht.
Aber der Patient fühlt sich fieberisch.
Er hat nicht gemessen, er kann es nicht sagen.
Kann aber sein.
Bekommen Sie sauerstoch zu Hause?
Bisher nicht, nein.
Ich habe hier noch Müdigkeit abgefahren.
Begreifstimtome, ich finde das Gefühl,
dass es nicht so ist, dass es nicht so ist.
Also, Tariqa, die weiß er nicht.
Er hat keine Herzrasen gemerkt.
Er steht nicht auf, deswegen kann er nicht sagen,
ob er im Bett steht, aber im Bett liegen sitzen hat er kein Schwindel.
Und Müdigkeit abgeschlagen hat, ja, er kann sich kaum bewegen.
Wenn man das so will, kann man das als Abgeschlagenheit bezeichnen.
Ich habe alle Fragen gestoppt, ich denke,
können wir als Herzgeschichte anfangen?
Danke schön.
Bitte schön.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen
diese Patienten besprechen.
Darf ich erst den Patienten vorstellen?
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen
diese Patienten besprechen.
Darf ich erst den Patienten vorstellen?
Ihr seid für mich?
Ja, der Patient heißt
Rainer Kaalmont.
Herr Kaalmont ist
67 Jahre alt,
1,70 m
groß und über 100 cm schwer.
Herr Kaalmont,
ich würde gerne mit Ihnen
das Patienten besprechen.
Herr Kaalmont stellte sich
bei uns wegen seit gestern
nachmittag
Progradkender
Diszipline
und
Hüsten
wie Brust
oder Angina
und
Herr
der
als begleitetes Zeptomen sei
ihm
die Folgenden aufgefallen
ödeme
ausführ
gelb gründliche
und
dann
Orthopne
der Patient
seit
der Patient seit
jahr
leider an
COPD
und der Patient berichtet das
er früher
er hat haben
aber seit gestern
seit gestern
diese Beschwerden
sind
und die vegetative
Anamnese
seit einige Auffälligkeit
insbesondere
in Zomni
wegen der Atemnot
und
die
Nektürie
dann
die Fragen nach
Fibersuperfrost
wurde verneid
und vor Erkrankungen leide
an seit 2 jahren
Diabetes Melitus seit
Sinjarin Arterielle Hypertonie
seit 4 jahren
und
er habe letzten jahr
im Fark gelitten
er wurde
2-7-tämpelt
und
er nehme
die folgende Medikamente regelmäßig ein
Zerdeans 10 mg
morgens
und Ramipril 5 mg morgens
bis April 2,5 mg
morgens und abends
SS 100 mg morgens
Plavix
morgens
Plavix Tablet morgens
Atorvastatin 20 mg abends
Metformin 1000 mg morgens
abends
und Salbutamol spray
bei Bedarf
und Multiple spray
Tegris
und er
sei
wegen
Appendicitis
operiert worden
er sei mit
Kinderheit
wegen Appendicitis operiert worden
allergie
und unverträglichkeit
er habe keine Ahnung
oder keine Unverträglichkeit
er sei
Rauha
ungefähr 50 Packet
jahrels
er sei
keine Alkoholkonsumiert, Drogenkonsum
wurde verneit
er sei verwidert
und er
habe keine Kinder
er sei Rentner, aber früher
als Kraftfahrer
gearbeitet
und ihre Familie
seine Mutter wegen
Mama Karcinom gestorben
und sein Vater
herztödlichen Infarkt gestorben
Aufgrund der geschilderten
Septome des Patienten
gehe ich von Pferdach
auf Pnomoni
aus
und
Differenziell Diagnose
mit
Lungel
und
Akut
Coronazendron
und
in Betracht
Was haben Sie mit den Patienten gemacht bisher?
Welche und welche
Untersuchungen haben Sie schon eingeleitet?
Haben Sie mal abgehört den Patienten?
Wie bitte? Haben Sie den Patienten ausgotiert?
Ja
Was haben Sie gehört?
Beschreiben Sie mal den Ausgotationsbefund
Ja
bei Körperlihe
und Untersuchungen
erwarte ich
Atemgeräusche
so
fein
Geräusche
oder
Citridors
zu hören
Wie ist das normale Atemgeräusch, wenn Sie ausgotieren?
Bei gesundem
Menschen
können wir
brunschiale
Geräusche
wie ist das normale?
Atemgeräusch
bei einem gesunden
Menschen
beschreiben Sie das normalerweise, wenn Sie den Styliskup aufsetzen?
Ja
nennt man vesikuläres Atemgeräusch
vesikuläres Atemgeräusch
Wenn Sie jetzt einen Patienten haben mit
Pneumonie, wie kann das Atemgeräusch dann sein?
Kann natürlich auch vesikulär sein, aber es gibt auch
andere Befunde, manchmal
wenn Sie Patienten mit Pneumonie abhören, was können Sie da hören?
Ja
Fein oder Rasselgeräusche
Rasselgeräusche, genau
Was sind das für Rasselgeräusche, die Sie hören bei Pneumonie?
Ja
Es gibt zwei grobe Einteilungen
Früchte oder trockene?
Ja, das freute Rasselgeräusche
und meistens diese Feinblasen-Rasselgeräusche bei Pneumonie
Was sind trockene Atemgeräusche?
Trockene Atemgeräusche
Wir hören
Also zu den trocken Atemgeräuschen
können diese typischen
Asthma oder
Spassmischen Geräusche
zum Beispiel, Begemen, Brummen, Pfeifen
und was kann auch noch sein
wenn Sie eine Pneumonie haben
und Sie haben
keine feuchten Rasselgeräusche, was kann auch noch sein?
Ja
Bei Kindern ist das interessant, da hört man selten
Rasselgeräusche, das hört man bei Kindern, die in der Pneumonie haben
manchmal, also nicht immer, aber manchmal
Ja, das ist ja auch ein Problem
Ja, das ist auch ein Problem
Also
bei Atemgeräuschen oder
Auskratation
Bei Auskratation
Wir hören so meistens
ein abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch
Abgeschwächt
Abgeschwächt, also leiseres Atemgeräusch
Also normales, versikuläres Atemgeräusch
Wenn es Pneumonie ist, also die Lunge enduriert ist
dann hören Sie manchmal ein verschärftes Atemgeräusch
Dann gibt es noch mal bei einer Atelektase
Da haben Sie Atelektasen, dann eine Pneumonie zum Beispiel
Dann hören Sie einen abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch, weil die Belüftung nicht da ist
Und dann kann man noch durch diese zuerzt Geräusche
feuchten Rasselgeräusche noch einschätzen
und jetzt die Richtung gehen kann
Das hören Sie bei Patienten, die eine COPD haben
schon seit 10 Jahren
Was hören Sie da? Wie klingt das Atemgeräusch bei denen?
Ist eher verschärft
Wenn Sie jetzt keine Pneumonie haben, meine ich jetzt
Kann sein, dass Sie gar nichts hören, das ist ein Silent Chest
Die hört drauf, man hört gar nichts
weil die Infusee haben
Das ist ein kleiner Ausglock
zur Ausglockationskunde der Patient
Eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose wäre noch bei den Patienten
der schon seit 10 Jahren eine COPD hatten
Nach der Medikamente hat es bezüglich
nach Risikofaktoren wäre, dass sie eine
Infekt-Exerziation hat der COPD
eine Exerziative COPD, also keine Pneumonie
sondern Exerziativerdiagnose
Das wäre jetzt meine Verdachtdiagnose gewesen bei den Patienten
Wie gehen Sie dann voran, wenn Sie denken
Pneumonie oder Infekt-Aktion, was machen Sie?
Ausglockation haben Sie gemacht, das ist wichtig
Das muss man immer machen, bevor man Patienten drinnen schickt
Das habe ich schon verraten
Wir haben Sie gesagt, von den Dorax
Was haben Sie genug Tests, die Sie machen, damit Sie
einschätzen können, wie kritisch der Patient ist?
Ja
Bei der Röntgen
erwarte ich
eine
Schadel
Verschattung
Schadung
Pneumonie-Werbeer
Wir haben gesagt, der Patient hat am 1. September
eine exerziative COPD, sehen Sie da etwas im Röntgen
Wenn ich so frage, dann nicht
Kann sein, dass Röntgen normal aussieht bei den Patienten
Stießt ja eine Infekt-Axerziative COPD nicht aus
Wenn Röntgen normal aussieht
Können Sie höchstens sagen, dass er keine Pneumonie hat
oder es keine radiologisch nachweisbarer Pneumonie
Was machen Sie noch, außer Röntgen?
Der Utroximeter ist so 89
Mit Sauerstoff ist es bei 92
Was machen Sie noch für die Patienten?
Nein, Blutuntersuchung
Blutgasanalyse
und CRPD
CRPD und kleine Blockbild
dann
Sedimentation der Physik
Das kann sein
Sedimentation
Ausstoß an Differenzialdiagnose
Und bei
Unserer Falle
Hemoglobin A1C
und Glucoswerte
Was machen Sie noch, wenn Sie an diese Differenzialdiagnosen denken
die Sie genannt haben
Was soll man auch auf jeden Fall machen?
Zum Ausschluss
Lungenambollier
werde ich
Dedi-Mar
und Fibonoyer
Biber-Prüffer
Das zweite nicht verstanden, also Dedi-Meyer
und danach, was noch? Ich glaube, das ist halt nicht verstanden
Dedi-Mar und Fibonoyer
Fibonogen, das kann man machen
Muss man aber nicht machen, glaube ich
Was machen Sie noch, wenn Sie an Lungenembollier denken
Ja
Zum Ausschluss
Ich werde mit
komputerer
Angiografie
veranlasen
Nur wenn Sie einen Hochgrading verdacht haben
bei dem Patient ist ja nur eine kleine Differenzialdiagnose
da würde ich jetzt etwas anderes machen, bevor ich eine CT-Angiografie mache
Also Blutgas haben Sie schon gemacht
Blutgasanalyse haben Sie gemacht, atarielle BGA
haben Sie gemacht oder Kapilläre von mir aus
Also Blutgasanalyse brauchen Sie auf jeden Fall
damit Sie wissen wie die Sauerstoff-Patialdruck ist bei den Patienten
und es entscheiden wie kritisch das Ganze ist
weil Sie müssen überlegen, ob Sie den Patienten auch
beatmen müssen zum Beispiel, nicht invasiv, kann ja sein
Also BGA auf jeden Fall
und dann würde ich, wenn die Differenzialdiagnose-Emboli
im Raum steht, aber jetzt auch nicht sehr wahrscheinlich ist
aufgrund von klinischen Angaben, die jetzt in die andere Richtung gehen, was würden Sie machen
denn würde ich jetzt nicht ein CT-Schicken den Patienten, sondern was würde ich machen, wenn überhaupt
Okay, also wir haben noch
die Differenzialdiagnose-ACS genannt
Also der Mann ist auf jeden Fall in der EKG
von mir ist auch ein Troponin, das können Sie auch machen
und wenn das aber normal aussieht und Sie wollen die Lunge-Emboli
trotzdem noch ein bisschen weiter abklären, was machen Sie noch
gucken, ob er eine Rechtsherzbelastung hat, wie gucken wir das nach
Rechtsherzbelastung
Ja, Ökokardiografie
Genau, dann können wir uns schätzen, dann kann man da zumindest mal grob
die Richtung bestimmen, welche Richtung es geht
dann haben Sie es gemacht und sehen Sie jetzt keine Pathologiker
und dann würde ich eh in Richtung dieser Verdachtsdiagnose-Infekt
extrazibli-COPD denken
und was würden Sie dann machen, wenn Sie diese Verdachtsdiagnose haben
ist der Patient eher, sag ich mal ein Patient, den man ambulant
behandeln würde oder eher ein Patient, den man stationär
behandeln würde, klar, der hat jetzt
Sauerstoff-Paziatok, haben Sie jetzt gemessen
der ist noch über 60 oder so, 65
und jetzt geht es sich also, geht so, ja
Was würden Sie denken, ist das ein Risikopatient
gucken Sie mal an seine klinischen Angaben oder ist
kein Risikopatient, nachdenken Sie
für Prämonie
für die stationäre Antibiotikaterapie, das würden Sie
für die Stationäre Antibiotikaterapie, das würden Sie
tun, wir sollen
Kurb
Arten, der Patient über
65 Jahre alt und
so
er
hat auch COPD
und
ja, wir
sollen
Er wird mit dem Sauerstoff kontrollieren und Herrsrat und Blutgasanenis.
Aber ich würde sagen, dass der Patient auf stationär aufgenommen wird.
Antibiotikatherapie, die haben gesagt.
Antibiotisch, Antibiotische, Muslime, Perapraischno,
nach der Entzündungsschwerthe und Blutkultur.
Hat er gesagt, genau.
Ich habe jetzt mal vorausgesetzt, dass die Entzündungsschwerthe leicht erhöht sind.
Also neukalte Tose von 10.000 und CHP,
der CHP, bei Grenzbett von 5 hat er vielleicht so 50.
Also spricht für eine Entzündung.
Röntgen war negativ.
Er hat schon richtig gesagt, aufgrund seines Alters,
er ist älter, klar muss man es abhängig machen
von den Blutgasanalysewerten,
Parikadi und Taripnöhe natürlich.
Aber er hat Risikofaktoren, zustande nach Herzinfarkt.
Er hat dir bitte das Meditus, er hat bekannte COPD,
vielleicht auch, wenn man nicht nach der Therapie,
wo der sein sollte,
man sollte mindestens ein höheres Stadium, Goldstadium,
ja, Goldstadium 3 vielleicht sogar.
Und dann wäre es ein Risikopassent, den man dann auch stationär
machen würde mit Antibiotika.
Sonst kann man überlegen, ob man das ja ambulant macht.
Meine Praxis, welche Antibiotika fährt gleich wieder?
Dann wir fragen wir den Doktor.
Welche Antibiotika ist?
Ist es einfach, diese Station?
Issa, antibiotika bitte.
Antibiotika, ja, erste würde ich
sepolosporin Antibiotika verabreichen.
Wer anopplonen, ja.
Also wenn der Patient jetzt leichte Symptome hat,
also sei ich mal in der Therapie,
die man ambulant eher machen würde,
kann man ganz normales Aminopennicilin geben.
Das ist ein etwas risikoreicher Patient mit auch Komplikation.
Dann würden Sie das halt stationär machen, auch untervenüsst.
Dann können Sie entweder Aminopennicilin mit Petylactamase
Aktivität oder sepolosporin geben.
Und Alternative, wenn er eigentlich Allergien hat,
kann man auch über Blurchinolone nochmal nachdenken.
Aber sepolosporin werden auch Medikamente in der Regelung ziehen würde.
Wenn der ambulant bleiben sollte, also wenig Symptome
und wenig Entzündungsreaktion,
dann hat eine Penicillinallergie, was würden Sie dann geben?
Ja, ich würde eine Makrolite Antibiotika wählen.
Oder Elektromysin oder Claritromysin.
Ja, genau.
Gut, alles klar.
Was sind Komplikationen?
Oder können Sie mir ganz kurz noch erzählen?
Die Einteilung der COPD, wie man die Einteilt, Plastifikation,
wissen Sie das noch?
Plastifikation, ja, COPD wurde nach Gold, Goldkriteria geteilt,
ja, vier Studium geteilt.
Erste Studium.
Warum ich nicht aufsucht sehe?
Das macht man ja dann, wonach macht man das fest,
Goldstadium 1 bis 4, wonach entscheiden Sie das?
Was ist das für die Goldeinteilung?
Ja, bei erstes Studium, Schmerzentschuldigung,
nicht keine Atemnot oder keine Zepton.
Aber ja, man wurde wegen der Zepthalt
die COPD, Plastifikation, Plastifikation,
und dann können Sie nach Schwerekratz, Symptomlast,
Exerzapation, häufig können Sie noch den A bis A, B, C, D machen,
beziehungsweise nach der neuen auch CD, C und D,
bezogen als E.
Das können Sie nochmal nachlesen, und das ist nach der
Symptomatik und der Häufigkeit der Exerzapation
einzutalen, ja, genau.
Und was sind denn die Komplikationen bei COPD,
bei langer COPD?
Ja, COPD, verursacht, rät, herrs, infos, ja, es ist sehr wichtig.
Und dann...
Ich zertse das Bezirken.
Oft Atem-Ax-Faktion?
Genau, Atem-Ax-Faktion, sehen Sie denn genau.
Was ist noch? Problem? Komplikation?
Unserer Fall, die Akutexervation, sehr gut.
Genau, ja, und Sie haben ja auch zwischendurch gefragt,
ob er Sauerstoff hat.
Also kann sein, dass er passend Sauerstoff,
Langzeiterabieraufbrauch, ja, das ist noch die Komplikation,
die auch diese verschiedenen Problemen,
die ja im Herbühne, MPV, im Korb-Pulmonale,
und woher sterben meistens dann die COPD-Patienten?
Man infektion, klar, aber woran sterben die noch?
Woher sterben die?
Stärben die an Luftnot? Ja, schon, aber die haben
andere Komplikationen.
Da müssen Sie in Leichenschein schauen,
dann steht das alles auf der Sache akut.
Ja.
Herzinsuffizienzen, ja, Sie haben karniale Probleme.
Herzinsuffizienzen.
Ja, das ist der, mein Herzproblem.
Herzinsuffizienzen, weil deswegen, es ist bei den Patienten auch so,
da hat er auch angegeben, dass er diese Patientin,
die immer knöchel dem hat, ja, das ist zum Beispiel auch
oft ein Phänomen, was man bei diesen Patienten beobachten kann.
Und manchmal ist auch gar nicht schwer zu unterscheiden,
hat ein Patient jetzt jetzt eine COPD-Exerzerpaktion
oder hat er jetzt einen linksherzigen Subizienz zum Beispiel,
also dieses typische Asthma-Kardial,
das kennen Sie auch, das manchmal gar nicht so leicht zu differenzieren,
wenn die Symptome nicht eindeutig sind.
Okay, gut.
Dann haben wir ein paar Sachen noch besprochen.
Ich würde Sie sagen.
Ich habe das nicht geholt, was im Chat alles geschrieben worden ist, aber...
Ja, aber man kann auch die Diagnose, die differenzialen Diagnose geben.
Unsere Patienten hat eine Diagnose,
eine akute Extraterivation der COPD ist richtig.
Ja, schön, das ist die Hauptdiagnose,
aber die differenzialen Diagnose bei solchen Patienten
ist schwierig, ja, es kann Herzinfarkt wieder sein,
es kann Lyme-Embolese sein, kein Phenomenese,
und es war alles schon sehr richtig gemacht, ja.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Dann sind wir für heute durch, ja.
Ich habe schon eine Stunde vergangen,
aber ich habe nicht gemerkt, ging schnell, ja.
Und, was machen wir mit dem Kollegen?
Hat die Prüfung bestanden oder nicht?